There are three elements that can change in the scene. The light's directions,
the eyes position, and the objects orientaion. In the first answer, the object
does not move. This means the objects normals are the same each frame. The
lights can still move. If the lights move, the shade of the object will change,
so we can rule out this answer. The second answer locks down the eye position
and the light's directions. Now the lights cannot move, but the object could
rotate in space. If it does, the directions of its normals compared to each
light will change, which changes the diffuse calculation. So this answer won't
work. The third answer locks down the lights directions, and the object's
orientation. The eye position is not locked down, and so can move and change the
direction it is looking in. However, the two elements that affect the diffuse
lighting equation are the lights directions, and the objects normals. Eye
direction is unimportant, as the diffuse material has the same shade from any
direction it's viewed. So this answer is correct. The fourth answer keeps the
objects orientation fixed, but like the first answer, the lights can change
directions. Surface shading can change. So this answer is incorrect.